[Musique]
ce lundi 19 décembre la présidente du
département a remis les attestations de
formation 1,19 contrat unique
d'insertion et du service civique qui
partiront prochainement travailler dans
la zone océan indien
ils sont tous demandeurs d'emploi et
elles peuvent être embauchés ou en tant
que service civique ou en tant que série
payé par non pour aller faire de la
coopération dans les pays de la zone
océan indien
moi je vais partir comme animatrice de
clubs de français je vais travailler à
diego suarez dans un lycée public
je pars aux seychelles en tant que
coordonnateur de projets écotouristiques
donc pour le classement au patrimoine
mondial de l'unesco des seychelles le
conseil départemental favorise la
mobilité l'insertion professionnelle de
réunionnais qualifiés bénéficiaires du
rsa avec le recrutement et la mise à
disposition de ces personnes au profit
de pays de structures de la francophonie
les personnes qui sont qui bénéficient
de contrats uniques d'insertion qui sont
recrutés par département ce sont des
personnes qui sont diplômés bac 2 à 5 de
plus de +5 et
qui ont peuvent avoir un parcours très
très différents en fait sont pas
forcément il n'y a pas forcément un
profil type
après pour les personnes qui sont
[Musique]
volontaires du service civique l'alleud
les diplômes sûrement sont moins élevés
mais la volonté de découvrir l'autre et
la capacité d'adaptation et doit être la
même en faire les volontaires du service
civique seront recrutés pour un an
les contrastes les bénéficiaires de
contrats uniques d'insertion sont
engagés recruté pour un an renouvelable
une fois
aujourd'hui ce sont 162 personnes qui
sont partis grâce à ce dispositif
une expérience qui permet ensuite à ces
personnes d'avoir une employabilité
augmenter et de s'insérer plus
facilement dans la vie professionnelle
[Musique]